if I were born 10 years later you know
but for the grace of God
there's no doubt in my mind that I would
have transitioned I got really involved
in like feminism about like 10 odd years
ago I think what sucked me into it in
the first place was this kind of
revelation of like everything is
socially constructed and it became quite
clear to me that it's just like no
that's not the case the fact that I was
autistic getting diagnosed was what
helped me there is there is a link I
think it's something like 40 percent
yeah yeah yeah your transition are
autistic yeah yeah why are we talking
about this letting children do whatever
they want is not kind no and it might
make you feel like you're doing the kind
of thing and the whole society can tell
you it's kind but what we're doing now
is like the least kind thing
that can never be done to
you
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
our fantastic guest today is somebody
you have not seen on the podcast circuit
she's in fact the first person that we
ever hired to work with us here at
trigonometry she edits most of the
videos that you guys see and she has a
very interesting story to tell about
some of the things that we talk about
regularly on the show so if it's been a
welcome to trigonometry thank you it's
nice to be here bit weird but yeah a bit
weird to be on on the other side of the
camera exactly uh it's great to actually
have this conversation you've been
building up to it for a long time we'll
get into the stuff that you want to talk
about and we want to ask you about
before we do though what has been the
journey that's taken you to be sitting
here because you were the first person
we hired as I said you emailed us saying
hey do you you know are you looking for
anybody and it kind of took off from
there but what's been your journey
through life yeah
um yeah well I I come from Chelmsford in
Essex that's what I was born I moved to
Brighton which is
um
for anyone who doesn't know it's like
the Portland Oregon of the UK so it's a
very very Progressive place
um I got really involved in like
feminism about like 10 odd years ago
um because I was trying to do
the right thing at the time it was it
was that kind of um liberal feminism of
that sort of in sectional it's totally
different from the family and she met us
yeah
um but yeah so I was really involved
with that um and I would have considered
myself at that point
woke like I actually like I've found
diary stuff from that time and I
actually did call myself woke it was
like not a pejorative just actually you
know and I was proud of it and I was
very like into that Progressive stuff
and then
well long story short on that one I I
got very disillusioned with it when I
saw that it didn't actually marry up
with like reality and there was a bit
there were some good good seeds seeds of
Truth in there but I moved away from
that
um but I was really really passionate
about the truth and doing the right
thing and doing what's good and right in
the world
um and that's kind of why I never really
kind of
make fun of or
you know I don't think people are stupid
on the other side because I'm like I
know a lot of them are really
well-meaning and a lot of them they just
they want to be they want to do the
moral right thing in their lives and
that was what was giving me at the time
um anyway so I I then I got
um really into listening to uh Douglas
Murray who's the gateway drug to
um
basically leaving behind a lot of the
letters and I had at the time I was
really passionate about
um yeah getting to the truth and I just
saw these people that a lot of people
had been on the show
um speaking this truth that
I realized it just wasn't wasn't
marrying up with what people said about
what these people are like these people
are evil racist bigots and I was like
well if I actually listen to what they
say that's not the case and so I kind of
flipped from being on the far left to
being
um well not on the far right yeah I'm
not sure
legitimate right
um
I go to extremes and I've been finally
finally finding my place on on that
stuff anyway but then so I started
listening to a lot of this stuff and
then
um I found trigonometry
um in during the lockdown actually the
first lockdown
um and I was just like someone said my
friend Ruth was like oh just check this
out I think you'll like this and I
looked through the feed and I was like
oh my gosh it's like all the people I
love and listen to and so
um got hooked on that and then I
messaged you guys being like you know
hey can is there anything I can do to
help and unbeknownst to me at that time
young sweet Anton who's the producer
um was completely um
inundated with stuff and and so I I
stepped in and pretty much took over
from there you absolutely did and look
actually the thing that we want to talk
to you about isn't wokeness necessary
but I was curious that you said that you
were obviously we've talked about this
before she's spilling water on herself
she's got coffee and Classics though um
yeah you were talking about the fact
that you were in this kind of liberal
feminist mindset yeah and then you
mentioned that it didn't marry up to
reality which is what sort of shook you
out of that to some extent yeah what was
it that made you think that it didn't
marry up to reality like what were some
of the conf the clashes between reality
and ideology that you experienced yeah
uh good question
um there was a lot of stuff
like I think what sucked me into it in
the first place was this kind of
revelation of like everything is
socially constructed so for example you
look at things people come to you and
they say
um well why do we have blue as the boy
coloring pick for the girl color and you
go oh yeah they're just arbitrary colors
they you know but we've assigned this to
them and then a lot of stuff was
you see stuff and I still see it online
about like children's clothes and it's
like all the boys clothes are like
building and fighting and you know
triumphing all the girls clothes are
like be kind you know be sweet lovely
um and at the time
The Narrative was everything is socially
constructed so there's no difference
between men and women's at all it's
literally just how we socialize them in
society and I really bought into that
even to the extent where I didn't
believe that there was such thing as
someone being subjectively beautiful
like I remember arguing with someone
being like are you anything she's
beautiful because you know you've been
socialized that way and all this kind of
stuff really yeah legitimately
um so I was like online in in line with
the thinking you even like the kind of
thinking you see now which is like
no disrespect but people being like
obese with a shaved head and like loads
of piercings but saying like I'm I'm a
tent and I'm just as attractive as this
person who just don't understand it
because you've been you know anyway but
uh but the crap so sorry to interrupt
yeah you know what that makes your point
so well about you know the people on the
other side of there is such a thing yeah
uh are not stupid because you're an
incredibly smart person uh and
well you're very intelligent but for you
to believe something that factually
incorrect is quite incredible right
because our standards of beauty are
based on biology yeah yeah ratio and
yeah all of that Symmetry and all of
that yeah so it's it's so interesting
that that you could have been persuaded
to think that yeah yeah yeah well the
thing is I'm a bit of an all-nothing
person and so when I was saw the seed of
this I jumped into it I started seeing
everything through that lens and
actually
um quite quickly
um because I went into it Full Throttle
like I I saw
the Fort Smith very quickly as well
because you know just like
it it's a sort of a blessing and a curse
because it kind of means that I can
throw myself into something and I can be
in it like fully in it and then see the
problems like very quickly as well um
but yeah so I started to see how this
just doesn't marry up with reality and I
started to understand well actually
you know there are reasons I started
learning a little bit more about the
differences like between men and women
like neurologically
um and you know in terms of our bodies
and everything and it became quite clear
to me that it's just like no that's not
the case and again even with the thing
about as I said School uh sorry not
school clothing in like shops
it's the message that you get at the
time was
you know boys and girls are blank slate
and we've socialized girls to be into
flowers and pretty things and the boys
into this
but the reality is is that
the market is following the response the
market isn't interested in like churning
out like strong boys and and weak girls
or whatever the market is just following
up people like and yes there is probably
an element well there's definitely an
element of
um girls get socialized into it because
that's the majority thing but it's also
like the reason that you know if they
started you know putting loads of
um
if they put them boys clothes stuff on a
lot of the girls clothes stuff
um you know when they're old enough to
choose their own they're not going to
choose it they are the girls are more
likely to choose the the kind of
princess dress over the Spider-Man
outfit like you know most most girls
um so yeah I just realized this is it's
more complicated than that than what I'd
initially thought and there are other
things for you Sophie you've always been
a fascinating person to me
have one of the things that I really
enjoy talking with you yeah about with
you is autism being neurologically
atypical when did you realize that you
were autistic and you saw the world in a
different way yeah
well that was around well actually I
always kind of knew it because I had
sensed it in many ways actually funnily
enough a lot of the things I've
discovered about autism I had no idea
we're connected to autism at the time
when I got diagnosed so I was diagnosed
when I was 25 so that's
um so that's 2015. it's not actually um
it's not actually that uncommon to get
diagnosed that late in life you know for
most girls actually is that's changed
now because people are thinking about a
lot more but most women who are
diagnosed were diagnosed in adulthood
because they benefit they manifest
differently in terms of the boys tend to
kind of act out and have meltdowns in a
very like explosive in school and the
girls are just kind of like I like rules
and just like working and like high
Achievers and so I was like that I was
like all the way through school it's
like achievement you know and I did my
school my you know college uni and then
um but the problems didn't really arise
until after uni because
um
everything happened to that point was
very structured and then you finish uni
and it's like I literally have the
entire world of choices and I don't know
what to do and like the paralysis of
that
um and other problems that I had with
not being able to respond to change
executive functioning skills so life
management skills
um just got me to a place of complete
um breakdown really like I literally
like just not not being able to function
in the world and I was very ashamed of
that because at the time I didn't know
it was autism
so I just thought I don't get it like
I'm really high achieving and get get
high grades and you know a good degree
and everything but I can't like do the
washing up and I know you know and a lot
of that's through sensory issues and as
well
um but yeah so there was a lot of shame
that I had attached to that and for
other reasons which we'll go into but
but yeah the warning signs are always
there but it is the black and white
thinking and the kind of really extreme
thinking
um you know which you know leads you to
sometimes call me an extremist
but also as well I mean you told that
story from your PE lesson and obviously
tell it because you're going to tell it
a lot better than me when it comes to
identification and gender ID so yeah
yeah yeah yeah so yeah so another part
of um
my experience let's just set the context
a little bit Yeah because I think the
issue that we've talked a lot about on
the show as you well know is how I do I
mean and this is why I asked you about
wokeness because it it just shows you
how ideology is so powerful yeah that it
can convince you even a very smart
person like you and like me and like
everyone really of things that are just
patently not true yeah but ideology is a
very powerful thing and one of the
things we've talked a lot about on the
show is the the rise in transgenderism
and young children in particular
identifying out of their gender and so
on yeah how that marries up to you know
a lot of the other stuff particularly in
relation to autism I mean there's
there's a clear link yeah people who are
autistic and people who are
transitioning and a lot of people
essentially are making the argument that
the overwhelming majority of the
increase in recent years is
um basically autistic and gay children
yeah
sort of looking for an answer to why
they're different yeah and ending up in
this new thing yeah and the reason we
wanted to have you on is that that is
actually to some extent your experience
so yeah tell us tell us that yeah now
that we've said that up yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah it's weird I'm about to tell my
story to however many people
um but yeah yeah two yeah the cameras
are off
um
yeah I I
always experienced
thinking that I was a boy from a young
age
um and it's hard to explain what that
means because it's like what what does
that mean
um like and it wasn't that I wanted to
be a boy or like I was telling people
well I'm on board I'm actually a boy I
actually genuinely thought I was
um because and I didn't realize
um that I was a girl until something
would come along and remind me so I
think what you were referring to maybe
Francis was yeah like I think when I was
in assembly in primary school so I don't
know how old it was maybe like five or
something
um and the teacher asked us asked
everyone about no so the teacher asked
the boys specifically a question and I
started answering and I just remember
the boys next to me being like why are
you answering you're a girl and I was
like oh yeah I'm a girl yeah you've got
to remember that gotta remember that
um and it was kind of like that all the
way like I default
into thinking that I was male and that
other people saw me as male
um
and that carried on
all the way through my life really
pretty much until well until some stuff
happened later that you know has
alleviated that but but yeah like I had
that all the time like um and even when
I was like
25 like um my friends
um I had my hair cut and my friends are
like oh you know you should get some
lipstick um because at the time I I
don't think I'd really worn makeup apart
from when I've been forced to for a
special occasion but
um I didn't like you know girls stuff at
all I was completely like
I was just always with the boys and I
was just a massive tomboy and I didn't
like that stuff anyway
um yeah my friends were like oh let's
get you some lipstick and they sort of
marched me down to Boots and
um I mean obviously I love lipstick now
I love it now like it's actually it's
quite fun it's like a little sort of
coloring in book at the start of the day
every day which is fun for me but like
the
we went there they they put the lipstick
on me and I just genuinely felt like
just really like ashamed because
I just felt well I felt like a clown
first of all
um and then when I walked home wearing
the makeup I was just like
expecting everyone to look at me like
you know like you know because I thought
that they were seeing a man the way
people might look at a man wearing yeah
exactly and I thought that they were
they would see a man walking down the
street in drag so I thought I'd draw
like you know stairs but then I had to
remind myself oh no you're a woman and
so they're seeing a woman wearing
lipstick which is normal for them and so
like and that was the same when I was 25
before I was diagnosed so
um that was kind of my story all the way
through life and and it wasn't the done
thing back in those days too especially
not for girls to
um do anything about it because you
don't you just you just say I'm a tomboy
and I'm comfortable with these things
and I just carry on also there's no like
the reason why
um up until very recently with the whole
explosion of girls identifying as trans
it was pretty much all boys and I think
the reason for that one of the reasons
for that is that there's no socially
safe way for a boy to sort of
[Music]
um
gender bend as it were like for me I
just wore shorts and t-shirts and
whatever so I could wear boys clothes
but it didn't look like I was
cross-dressing whereas if you're a
little boy and you you hate being a boy
and you want to be a girl you know you
you'll start wearing dresses and then
you know you're gonna very quickly it's
gonna be evidence to everyone around you
that there's some incongruity going on
there and Sophie did you feel apart from
this one instance with the makeup did
this cause you particular distress did
you feel a sense of discomfort or
disgust for your own body which is what
some people talk about
um well actually interestingly I feel
like the pressure almost like in terms
of fit in with the narratives to say
yeah I I really you know had a problem
in my body I actually I actually didn't
I had because when you when you don't
have a choice to opt out of your gender
as so many teenagers are given the
choice now
you just get on with it and you know
realistically speaking there's not too
many moments in one's life where your
sex actually comes into play and so you
know you learn to use the bathroom with
this symbol on it the lady symbol
um and
that's it really and and when people
referred to me as women it was just a
little reminder oh yeah I mean there was
a bit of a there was
it did hurt
not being able to join in with the boys
and like so I explained when I talk
about gender dysphoria now which is what
it is you know it's the it's defined as
the persistent discomfort and distress
associated with your your sex I think
that's the right definition
um
when I
yeah when I experienced that
I talk about in in terms of like two
separate categories there's there's the
actual thinking I was a boy
and then there's the wanting to be so as
I the wanting to be wasn't there when I
was young but when I got older and I
would have a reminder that I'm a woman I
would then have feelings of
my life would be so much better if I
were a man and everything would be
I don't know like I just got really
annoyed with the seemingly arbitrary
things that were foisted on me as a girl
to to that seem to be valuable to other
people like in terms of looking after
your appearance or whatever like
um I mean like I have to wash my face
every morning yeah yeah yeah no but
seriously it's just like I mean like I
didn't like wash my hair do my hair and
I've talked about it before and I feel I
think my mum feels quite bad about it
but
and you know she basically said to me I
when I was like 13 or something like you
need to start washing your hair and if
you don't wash your hair like I will cut
the whole lot off and because it had
genuinely got to the stage of being like
matted and horrible and and
I was just so not bothered about that
stuff and I saw it such a waste of time
and such a stupid imposition that I just
I just couldn't care less anyway she did
cut all my hair off
about that um
you know that she's an evil mother but I
think it was the right thing to do to be
honest because it did make me back up my
ideas a little bit
um but uh but yeah so so there were um
sorry there were like uh those those
feelings but I think one of the
interesting things is I see a lot of
people who are going through gender
dysphoria online talking about their
hatred for their bodies but I was
different in that I I never thought
about my body like I don't think I
realized I had a body till I was like 23
or something
um which is obviously that's a little
bit
um exaggerated because of course you
know you have a body but what I mean is
I never thought about it like you know I
probably thought about my body about as
much as you think about your capillaries
do you mean like I know they're there or
or maybe like choose something that you
can actually physically see like I don't
know the crook of your elbows and things
like I know it's there I can see it but
I never think about it and I didn't
think about
um yeah so I actually you know contrary
to
yeah what a lot of people kind of
experience
with their sort of hatred of the body I
was just completely disassociated from
it and I actually so I had the blessing
of never being in any way dissatisfied
with my body because I just never
thought about it so I was just like it's
working it's functioning it's fine do
you think that's part of the problem now
is because of social media and gender
ideology that kids are now being
encouraged and in fact it could be
argued manipulated into an obsession
with their own bodies yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean like
I'm showing my age but we didn't really
have social media when I was growing up
back in the day
um yeah
um yeah so we didn't really have social
media so it was there wasn't that
fixation on I mean girls around me were
always kind of
uh you know especially in school the
girls were like you know doing their
hair and makeup and stuff but
I mean
I actually yeah I think I I developed
quite a lot of um sexism really against
women because of because of that because
I didn't understand the value of it and
I
yeah they always think they were vain or
something yeah yeah like I had a I had
when I was working through so I
obviously we will come to like how
because you know basically there was an
alleviation of my gender dysphoria
um
due to we'll get there yeah we'll get
there but
but yeah I realized that because of the
autism and my black and white way of
thinking there just wasn't any space for
like
um
there wasn't any space for nuance
artists don't do Nuance I mean I try
really hard to do it now because like
I care so much about the truth and the
truth is nuanced and so you have to like
I have to actively go against and type
to really really work on that because
it's important to me but
I basically just looked at the girls
were like
like you know why would you rather play
with a Barbie
than an action man an action man AB
sails and shoots missiles and you know
does cool stuff you know rock climbing
and where and and the Barbie is
literally just standing there with like
a mirror and I was just like and so it
blew my mind that other girls would
choose this and you know like now as I
say with a bit of nuance I understand
that you know dolls and things like that
are very good like
um social tools for learning many things
as
um and they're very very useful and
there's nothing wrong with choosing a
Barbie but at the time I just had so
much disdain for girls and that made me
disassociate even further to the point
where I didn't even consider myself one
of them and
so I had when I was working through
trying to get over my gender dysphoria I
met with one of the um
pastors of my church
um Stephen and he you know I were
talking about and I was like
ah like word I don't want to be a woman
women are so
um boring and just airheaded and all
they care about is their appearance and
you know like I know I'm I'm really like
um passionate about like philosophy and
and history and all these important
intellectual things and you know and
they just they're just not on my level
and he was like
yo you're being really sexist you need
to repent
um genuinely and I was like
that Ridge just really hit me because I
was just like
yeah I am I'm being sexist and what I've
done is I'd conflated all of the worst
things I'd seen about
um
this sort of picture of femininity I
built up in my mind to almost making an
enemy so if you've got an enemy you can
run away from it or fight it or whatever
um
and then I just realized that I mean
obviously that was sexist I'm and I'm
being a bit over the top about it but
so but yeah I had to work through that
because I realized that there's just so
many
that's so not true and like some of the
things that I had a problem with
adjust women just being women in the
same way that a lot of people have
problems with the things that are
masculine and they're just you know it's
just men being men a lot of the time and
it's like it's not
it's just it's just that I was an
outlier on the bell curve that I
resented that
this episode is brought to you by better
help Constantine what's the best thing
about having this episode sponsored by
betterhelp in my country mental health
is something that you have before you
start drinking thankfully it will start
drinking at breakfast so we have no
problem really yes our slogan is drink
breakfast vodka and become real men okay
but if you do want to feel better inside
and out then maybe you should try better
help I have been doing therapy for over
a year and it has really helped me
understand myself better and become far
more effective in both my work and my
personal life I always knew you were not
a real man pass me the Vodka therapy has
helped me transform myself so that I
take responsibility for my behavior and
my attitude you can't achieve your
dreams if you don't think you deserve to
every shot you drink make you feel
stronger what is problem and the great
thing about better help is that it's all
online and they can connect you with
their licensed therapist who can work
with you so that you can achieve your
goals it takes a few minutes to set up
and it can fit around your schedule I
will never forget my first love Olga
orgasmachenko and the Beautiful
relationship that could have been and if
it's not working for you with a
particular therapist then you can always
switch at no extra charge I am doomed to
become Russian poet discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com
trigger today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trigger
I have run out of breakfast Vodka it's
time for lunchtime Brandy
so can we come back chronologically a
little bit because
um one of the narratives in the modern
world is that a lot of
young people experience all of these
sort of feelings and thoughts around
puberty because that's when the shock of
reality of their biology comes in yeah I
know it's an intimate question but I
think it's relevant to this conversation
you would have gone through it did that
not have an impact yeah
literally not at all like I don't
remember when I started my period I
don't remember my body changing I don't
really literally I couldn't give you any
insight into that that's so interesting
it was like
yeah I I have not one memory of thinking
that that is fascinating that is so
interesting I think I noticed I think
once when I was in PE when I was in high
school I noticed that that I had hair on
my legs for the first time that's the
only memory I have yeah
um okay well moving on then
from the hairy legs conversation uh I'm
just curious to
um to to talk about the link with autism
yeah because this is something you've
done a lot of looking into how how do
these things connect yeah yeah well this
is the thing I think a lot of people
people know now that it does connect
yeah I think several years ago I was
tearing my hair up because I was just
like
finding out about
how the the fact that I was autistic
getting diagnosed was what helped me to
which was which helped me to heal really
from genders for it maybe not here
wasn't the right word but like it
alleviated it as I understood my autism
because it just explained it all and
um
yeah so I was looking into
um when I found out I had autism when I
got diagnosed I started looking into the
neuro science of it because obviously
autism is a neurodevelopmental condition
and so I started looking into
neurodevelopment
um I read this brilliant book by um
professor
Sir Simon Baron Cohen of Cambridge
University he's like the he's like the
world leading uh Authority on autism
really or one of them but he's also like
um world leaning in cognitive sex
differences so the way men and women's
Brains work differently so he's about
five minutes away from getting cancer
that's true enough yeah
um
so
uh I was reading his book he wrote a
book called The Essential difference
which um if it was brought out if it all
brought out 10 years ago probably would
have been to under stretch but it was
about I think it's about 20 years old
now but he basically
literature on the differences between
the way men and women think into this
you know very readable book and I'd
recommend anyone to read it but um one
of the things that I learned in that
book
um was
um the differences between
men and women in terms of what's called
empathy empathizing and systematizing
skill sets and so like this is kind of
this is just
putting a scientific label on what we
already know which is that generally
speaking the majority of men are more
interested in things and Concepts and
systems and like problem solving and
that and the majority of women are less
interested in that and more interested
in uh the kind of
um emotional side of life uh
relationship building looking after
children nurturing
um building that kind of thing and so
yeah I think summed up really it's that
most men are more interested in things
and most women are more interested in
people and those those are the bell
curves and obviously there's outliers
which will come back to but anyway so
um
then I learn about
the the extreme male brain theory of
autism because
the amazing thing that you know that you
know the combining is two fields of
autism and cognitive sex differences is
that if you look at the
uh brain of someone with autism
their brain is like an exaggerated
version of the male brain right so um
really high systematizing really low
empathizing
um and um
that's that's the same for men and women
I mean I've got a little graph that I
can put up but it shows the the
differences that you know you've got the
men and the women the the men are less
empathic and the women are more empathic
but they're quite similar and then down
the other end you've got
um really unempathic uh
men and women with autism anyway
um obviously
to learn that the autistic brain
is like a male brain on crack
you know started
to answer my questions because I think
at that before that I'd
thought there was something wrong with
me you know like I was
I was deeply ashamed because I I felt
like a failure as a woman before which
was one of the reasons I ran away from
it because
I
had such low levels of empathy I'm in
like the second percentile for
compassion
so you know 100 people in a room there's
like one person with less compassion
than me um and that's way lower than the
average for a male um let alone a female
and so
I'm a Christian as you well know the top
level Cruiser as you call me
and for me one of the really important
things to do is to love people and to to
be loving and and I think I again like
that's probably why I got involved with
feminism because at the time I was like
I want to fight I want to do the right
thing I want to you make the world
better for women
um
but yeah so this
injunction to be loving was so important
to me but I didn't feel loving feelings
right because I didn't have these
compassionate empathic feelings and I
was surrounded particularly in the
church with loads of amazing
um compassionate like pastoral women
and they were just and I just felt
nothing you know
and so I felt really deeply ashamed of
that but then when I so I thought I was
defective I thought I was a failure
really as a woman and then when I
started learning about the extreme male
brain stuff I was like well
like I'm autistic I'm not I'm not you
know I realized that I was just
um I wasn't a man you know I realized
that I was a just a rarer type of woman
um and and that was the key really that
just unlocked everything you know
because I mean it was gradual it was
like the key turned and then the door
opened really slowly
um because I yeah I did move quite
slowly into appreciating that but it it
started to explain everything because I
was like well okay
um I don't need to
I I was I did try I went for a few years
of trying really hard to sort of
be what I thought a woman should be
um in terms of I try some of it stood me
in good stead now in terms of like
helping people but I I I took a lot of
like lessons and training and like
pastoral care and so like I can I know
the right things to do like if someone
is in distress or like I'm not you know
if someone is grieving or stuff so I
I've learned actually a lot of practical
skills it doesn't mean their feelings
there but anyway um another one of my
elders or you know pastors same thing at
church really helped me with that
because before I was diagnosed with
autism I went to him and I was saying
you know I I feel really bad because I
haven't got these loving feelings and I
want to be loving and I want to you know
you know following Jesus footsteps and
you know love people
um but I don't feel these feelings and
he said you know like um
you know that he basically said
your
um perhaps you could be the one person
in a room where there's like a crisis
and everyone else is
overwhelmed by their emotions and you
know you know but you can be like see
through it and you know be like really
um
helpful in that situation and just use
your gifts and and
uh yeah that really helped me that
really stuck with me because I realized
that
yeah I was
I was trying to you know I was trying to
be the opposite of what I was
um and now I see actually that
the love primarily isn't about feelings
um like any
parent knows or you know the apparent
but you're a teacher um I think you
mentioned it once or twice
um and also isn't your mum from
Venezuela exactly yeah nailed it
um
yeah what was I say so you is it love
isn't necessary yeah it's about actions
I'm guessing well not even necessarily
like
you can this is a problem I think that
we really just
kind of messed up with over the last few
years that we we think to be loving to
someone is to just go along with
everything they want and
you know like if you're a loving parent
and your child wants like
chocolate like just before bedtime or
whatever you just say no you can't have
that and that's being loving in the
moment um and they feel like yo you hate
me or whatever like you want me to die
you know and but it's just like you
actually know what's best and what
you're doing is loving and you're the
but I think at the moment we are so
I think that the I'm one of the only
values that we that we kind of hold to
in this kind of sort of
[Music]
post-christiany sort of
fade failing liberal kind of
Western project is
one of the only things we have is be
kind we just have to be kind and nice
and that's how we know we're good people
and I think because we everyone wants to
be good I think I think most people care
about it they want to be good they want
to be on the right side of history and
what they're told now is the loving good
thing to to be is to be kind is to be
really
kind and so
but isn't tempered by truth and
you know I think
so
let's hear some criso stuff just
pre-warning but like the Bible says of
Jesus that he was full of grace and
truth
and I think that the Western project is
only
um flourished in as much as it's held to
those
that christly balance of grace and truth
I want to say grace I mean like you know
Grace compassion Mercy tenderness
um we need
it's it's nice to show Grace to someone
but you also need to
do the right thing and the thing that is
true your point is letting children do
whatever they want is not kind no and it
might make you feel like you're doing
the kind of thing and whole of society
can tell you it's kind but what we're
doing now is like the least kind thing
that can ever be done to children and
um I often think about this with
pronouns because like
um
if I were born 10 years later you know
but for the grace of God
there's no doubt in my mind that I would
have transitioned that I would have gone
the whole hog and that's the thing about
autistic people is like we go the whole
world if you notice yeah um just a
little bit it's just like I got into
Star Trek and like two weeks later I
bought like a full uniform
um and like that's just that's just me
but that's just autists like that's what
we're like and and and and you know
there's some duty to that and some
craziness but
going the whole hog
um
I would have done that with transition I
would have had a mastectomy I would have
you know it would have been it just
wasn't a solution at the time but like I
look back at that I'm just like
I can't believe
that
I can't believe that we're going to
we've gotten to a place in society where
we think oh it's okay like that that's
the loving thing to do just give them
what they want
um when
their children the literary children the
brain doesn't finish developing until
like 25 anyway but to to give you know
puberty blockers and and
you know medical intervention to
children it's just like absolutely
insane it's like how do we get to this
place
and I do think it's this lack of of like
truth and like the the value of like
freedom and being loving just didn't
seems the ultimate value and why do you
think as well because I think there must
be another reason I accept your point I
think that's a major part of it but the
link between Autism yeah and gender
dysphoria why is it that we that we are
not looking into that why are we not
studying that because that look that is
that there is there is a link I think
it's something like 40 yeah yeah yeah
the transition are autistic yeah yeah
why are we talking about this the the
hot the figures are scary like the
Tavistock like the CQC report on the the
Tavistock the jits clinic for the for
child gender uh transition
um
is like 50 had autism or um ADHD which
is very similar in some ways um there's
also
a report an article written by two of
the previous kids members of staff that
say that 50 of their like they did a
strategic sort of analysis and 50 of
them autistic
um
there are so many reasons why it's um
such an appealing Prospect to autistic
people
um yeah one of them is yeah like
obviously on the female side of things
you've got that kind of
yeah that neurological shift to the male
Direction so of course all your
interests are going to be similar to
your male peers all of everything you
see
like everything that's expected of you
which is kind of again as I say it's
it's natural and it's based on the it's
based on the majority like everything we
have in society is based on the majority
so it's like
um if you're an outlier that's that's
going to affect you badly but
so uh I think Francis question was more
about why is it that we don't look at
this obvious thing that staring Us in
the face yeah as a society dealing with
this issue yeah and we're not going well
look if autism is let's say it's a
comorbidity yeah is that maybe something
we should look at maybe we should yeah
you know yeah think about that yeah do
you see what I mean yeah 100
um the only thing I was just going to
say about the uh the other side of it
which is the boys thing is that because
you could say oh well the boys are
getting an extreme male brain so surely
there should be more manly but there's
so many other things that come along
with autism that are
that are going to affect you in terms of
your social impairment like if you are
um
if you're just socially delayed and and
autism is a delaying thing you know like
I was like the last in my class to learn
to read I was
um
yeah say I didn't know about my body
until there's you know my 20s I I I
didn't um
yeah I didn't make a friend until like I
was 10 or something
um so
um there's there's that delay and if
you've got that delay in your and you're
a boy and you're gonna be socially less
confident as well and the girls would
tend to
uh make friends of you more like the
autistic guys I know you know like they
most of their friends are girls because
they're more accepting of your quirks or
your your your own coolness or whatever
and so they take you under their wing in
a way
um and so you kind of get on the boy
side
um why don't we recognize it as a
problem in society I mean we are saying
oh it's one of the many comorbidities
you say oh you know a lot of people
um who are transgender they are some you
know a lot of them are you know ADHD or
a lot of them have autism but it's just
like we have totally neglected to
understand that there's a difference
between having a comorbidity and
something being the cause of something
um so like there was a study in 2019
um
would that that showed that of
um what was it
of those who identified as trans and
non-binary 42 met the criteria for an
Autism diagnosis
um
and you know obviously the normal rate
of autism in the general population is
about two percent so
um and Dr stack who led the study was
like
you know I don't know if he was a a
whistleblower so to speak more probably
just following the outcome of his study
but was just like we need to be
screening people for autism
anyone who comes in to ask about gender
stuff and yeah as I say the tragic thing
is that
we haven't looked into it but I think I
know the reason why we've been so
rubbish at looking into
[Music]
um
all of the comorbidities and problems
and causes I mean like if you look at
the like the stats on the Tavistock
from Hannah Barnes book um time to think
which is excellent piece of Journalism
um the stats are just terrifying it's
like 2.5 or something of the intake
didn't have any kind of major like
um issue with
uh like abuse or
um
uh yeah neurodivergence or I think 25 of
them have been in care
compared to 0.67 of the population like
a lot of them had had they were like 10
times more likely to have experienced
um abuse like sexual abuse I think
um there are all these things like the
self-harm there's OCD there's there's
all these different things and they
weren't looked up I think I know the
reason
um and the reason is like well I I split
Society I split life
as we know it history into two eras so I
think there's the era of old trans and
the era of new Trans and the era of old
trans goes up to about 2017 I'd say
around that period and then new the year
of new Trans is everything after that
and these are two wildly different uh
ways of looking at the trans experience
so
up until 2017.
um the way that we thought of the trans
experience was
like if you it wouldn't have been like
because I lived in Brighton as I say I
live in Brighton and you would sometimes
see a fellow in a dress ten years ago 15
years ago
and but if you'd spoken to him at the
time and you said like um oh you know
why why are you wearing a dress he might
say well
I know I'm a man but like I feel more
comfortable in women's clothes and I've
always related to women and I always you
know I've always identified with women
um but then when the shift happened
around 2017 people went from saying that
they identify with women so I identify
it as a woman and so we went from saying
I feel like something to I am something
and the repercussions of that that
little shift affect literally everything
like it is all the entire problem that
we have now is
all down to the shift and I can give you
Myriad examples but like the so I mean
we had Marcus Evans on the show a
whistleblower from the Tavistock he'd
been there for like 35 years
um you know consultant psychotherapist I
think and he said you know like
in the old days or you know before this
big shift and everything if someone
comes in saying you know I'm really
distressed you know like I I feel like
trapped in the wrong body or whatever
the treatment pathway for them was
exploratory therapy so it's like
um let's look at your life in the round
let's look at
um you know your relationship with your
parents relationship with your peers
um has there been any abuse any trauma
um what are your expectations what
actually means to be a man or a woman in
the world you know talk us through that
um and all these different things and
they explore those things but when this
new kind of way of thinking of saying
it's your identity and it's who you are
rather than just feelings that you have
came in
you can't do that anymore because if
your gender
is who you are
um
and you it's not that you feel like a
boy you can't treat something that you
are yeah quite yeah I mean it's like
it because it would be transphobic it'd
be like or it would be like
someone with Down Syndrome going to the
doctor they don't try to cure your Down
syndrome or then try and cure you of
being black it's just like I mean like
um because it's it's that would be okay
well no it's not even your identity it's
who you are it's intrinsic to your so
this is the thing so like
there's
in the old days it was seen as again the
reason I'm giving this 2017 cutoff point
is because uh something strange happened
there I think it might be to do with
people needing to shore up their sense
of being a good person in the wake of
brexit and Trump very very polarizing
year 2016 and people were desperate to
kind of
I think
no commits themselves and others that
they're on the right side and this was
the thing that came along and and you
have certain things that came along
around that time like India Willoughby
former guest of the show was on
Celebrity Big Brother in 2018. I'm a
real woman Amanda I want you to know
that yes a real woman okay I'm glad that
sinking here I'm going to say one more
time so it really penetrates I am a real
woman okay and then obviously around
that time you see the emergence of the
phrase like trans women are women and
and so and in fact if you think about it
when was the last time you heard someone
say identify as a woman they don't do it
anymore they don't even say that anymore
so it so it identifies these women
dropped so so now it's it's who you are
and as I say so once yeah I thought so
when I read time to think the the book
about the Tavistock
I thought I had this idea in my head
that
the kids are coming along to the
Tavistock being referred and
there must be some like it it can't just
be that they rubber stamped them and
said oh you know PB blockers there's
adults in the room it's all not the way
that people say in the media it's all
being properly located you would think
that because you're like this is a place
of clinicians it's on the NHS it's it's
being overseen there's no way and you
read the book and you're like oh flip it
actually was like that like there was so
much intervention from from like
mermaids and other like politicized
bodies and such a culture of fear
um that they were literally just being
like
okay uh well they had this thing called
this model called gender affirming care
which is
um you know an orwellian sort of uh uh
twisting of words really because you
know it's like you know to really affirm
someone it would be to say you're you're
brilliant just the way you are and you
don't need to change it then you don't
need to try and fit into these sex
stereotypes and you know you go for it
but anyway so this affirming care which
comes in with this idea of it's who you
intrinsically are
um that
just made everything a problem it's sort
of solidified it and it became the gold
standard not just the gold standard of
care but like
the American Psychological Association
and all these top bodies said this is
the way to care and if you're not doing
that if you're just exploring it like in
the old days you're kind of casting down
their problems sorry you're casting down
on their identity and who they
intrinsically are and it's not that
they've got a problem they've just
discovered the truth of who they are
um and but but this this problem this
shift from I feel like to I am this old
Trends where thinking this neutrons
we're thinking has affected everything
else as well so it's not just
um you know autistic and gay and other
vulnerable children being
um treated because of this
um you know in my mind a massive medical
Scandal
um and medical neglect but it's also
um
we see it in every area like in terms of
women's spaces
um because again it's like old trans
you've got a man who you know he feels
like a woman he feels comfortable moves
clothes fine but it's not going in the
women's change rooms because he's not
entitled to he's not a woman but now
it's like well he is a woman and
therefore you know he's entitled to that
that space and this is why
this is why I think people a lot of
people just think I don't get this trans
argument like why can't we just Live and
Let Live and why can't they just
reconcile because it can't be reconciled
I'm so conflict of Rights it's a
conflict of Rights and so the only way
that we can deal with these problems is
by going back just a few years ago just
what like seven eight years ago wherever
to you know live and not live wear what
you want call yourself what you want
like that's fine I don't mind I don't
care like no one cares how someone
dresses and chooses to live their you
know Express themselves but I'm sorry we
can't overreach into the area of you
actually are this and we're just and but
this is this is this is the great news
because um as I said before like the I
think the trans experiment has failed
because
we are seeing all these dominoes fall
when people are suddenly realizing that
the negative results of what's happened
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop Revival toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life
people are suddenly realizing that the
negative results of what's happened
because
um it started as I say 2017-18 started
building up online then we're going to
lockdown everyone's in their homes or
online for a few years
the real world implications of this new
Trans worldview
aren't manifested we come out of
lockdown we try to apply those
that that new way of thinking in the
real world and it's an absolute
catastrophe in so many areas and so you
see people starting to backtrack and and
like so in the last few months we've
seen like in terms of women's sports
we've seen great like changes in that in
terms of like World Athletics like World
cycling World Aquatics
pardon me
ooh deciding you know look we want to be
nice but at the end of the day we do
have to recognize that your body's you
know are different isn't talking about
male athletes and so they've said look
we don't want to discriminate but we're
gonna
have an open category so it's going to
be female category and an open category
so
um the you know the dominance Dominos
has started to fall in the sports area
um you know we've seen public backlash
to the gender self-id stuff like in
terms of the double rapist that was put
in a woman's prison
um uh in Scotland you know caused this
great you know people didn't realize
this was going on and again even someone
like me who's really involved in it I
still had to say
I need to check the sources here and
make sure this is actually happening are
actually men being placed in women's
prisons
because I thought that sounds like a
sort of Daily Mail made-up thing no
disrespected anymore but you know it
sounds like one of these sort of like
things
but you know I mean it sounds like a
sort of they're putting men in women's
but they actually are like around the
world and they have been doing so and
and so there's been pushback on that
this um rapist has moved out of the
women's prison and that's you know that
people are calling for more of that
that's taking a turn that's taking a
tumble
um then you've got like changing rooms
and stuff like Primark instituted gender
neutral uh changing rooms and then you
know surprise surprise people are coming
on you know
tick-tocks and I think you're making
great points by the way for real you
know and what you're saying is is true
but don't you think this says something
deeper about society as a whole yeah
that we as a society have come undone
from our Mooring so to speak yeah where
we will say things like her penis yeah
and no one bats an eyelid yeah I mean to
put it bluntly that is mental yeah the
thing is
I understand why you say it's mental
but I don't actually think it is mental
because I think if you do
if you like as I said when I was a
feminist before if you accept that
everything is a construct and everything
is up for being constructed
then
because what they've done is they've
said
we're going to expand the categories of
of the word man and woman they're not
saying I think people think oh someone's
saying that someone can become the
opposite sex they're not saying that
they're literally just saying that the
word woman
used to be you know like hogged by
biological women and now we're expanding
it to what it truly should be which is
to include you know uh uh women
biological women and men who want to be
women or call themselves that I think
the big problem here comes from the
invention of the concept of gender
itself well yeah
um feminists don't like hearing this
because they're the one that popularized
this aspect of it but
um it was kind of created as a way of
being able to opt out of femininity uh
so that you could say well I am a woman
but I'm not going to behave in the
stereotypical ways that women are
expected to behave and I understand the
need or at least a desire to do that
yeah
um but if you invent the concept of
gender everything else follows uh gender
isn't a word that applies to human
beings I mean animals don't have gender
yeah right and neither do human beings
but once you create the idea that you
can this can be a difference between
your sex and this other thing yeah this
is where you end up inevitable which is
why you say it makes perfect sense
because it makes perfect it does make
perfect because if you have gender then
a woman can have a penis yeah I
absolutely yeah and so this is why I say
to people because I I do speak about
this stuff and I try and help people to
understand it and I say like
I know I don't use the word gender
because it means different things to
different people but also because of
what you said and I say to people when
you hear the word gender just replace it
with feelings because because that's
what they are like and so so what I was
saying I
so it used to be the case that obviously
sex and gender were synonymous so if you
had a form and it asked you for your
gender in the 70s you knew they're just
meant sex yeah like and so you you'd
write male or female
but then as you say like it started to
be used in different ways and it started
talking about your roles and your
expression and it's things like that and
I think there is some utility to that um
that there's also problems with it and
then
but now as I say like if you add
identity onto it and you're saying it's
it's an inherent like innate thing about
someone that they have an identity sorry
that they have
like a sort of a gendered soul as people
have talked about
um then
then
yeah that that caused all these problems
and so I was I was chatting to the to
the boys
uh production boys uh I was trying to
work this out and I saying well look
if the word gender didn't exist at all
right but you wanted a word to explain
what gender is which is basically
ultimately I think it's about your
feelings and how you fit in with your
sex that that is it really because it is
it's it's dependent on your sex like by
definition because it's it's in relation
to your sex so it's like
um you know if you're transgender the
idea is that you
there's a transition from you know your
sex
so um so I said like if we didn't have
the word gender which is confusing so
many people because people think sex
gender same thing
and we just use the word uh fit thing as
in how you fit in and feelings and you
just said I have a fiddling and everyone
has a fiddling right okay so or t
fitzling if you want to pronounce your
t's but I'm from Essex so I don't
pronounce
um but yeah so and if and if you said
um
you know no form is going to ask you for
your fiddling every former is going to
ask you if it's relevant for your sex
and the word gender doesn't exist so and
then you come along and you say well you
know I really feel that I have a blue
fiddling or I have a pink fluffy
fittling it's like okay
that's fine but it doesn't affect
anything
whereas you know it I think the reason
it's so confusing is that
people actually think
that because it's the word gender which
they they know and associate with
something that's real in their mind they
can they sort of it I think it confuses
a lot of ordinary people that
um just do you see what I mean
absolutely it'd be so much easier if we
just got rid of the word gender well I
know that we can agree on that we can
agree on unfortunately uh it's now
running rampant as it were it is the
monster that was created and now it's
running rampant yeah we are starting to
see changes positive changes I think we
can all agree on what else do we need to
do because for me one of the most
worrying things as a former teacher
everyone can drink obviously is
gender-neutral toilets in schools when I
saw this come in my head was in my hands
because I just thought these are people
who have no understanding about what it
is like to be a teenage girl going
through puberty and the vulnerability
that these people these women feel girls
feel
but yeah
yeah I acknowledge that most well girls
feel some kind of vulnerability when
they are in puberty
um very good impression
um we got a lot in common me and Grant
um
yeah yeah no I I agree what can be done
yes well actually I
while there's a lot of mental stuff
going on I'm actually incredibly
encouraged
right now
um I don't think I think
I have a very strong sense that this
whole thing is is coming crashing down
right now I mean it's because you
haven't been to America Yeah well yeah
okay fine I know I know so obviously in
America it's different but we're very
different I I know and they've got this
massive profit incentive that we don't
have over here and which is you know one
of the main reasons why I think that
it's it's continuing to go along there
but I think people are starting to push
back and you know we are seeing we've
seen so many things this is like I was
talking about these dominoes falling or
if you want to think about it in terms
of a Jenga block you know like all these
things are being pulled out like you've
got yeah like the Tavistock being closed
down and like the massive public shaming
of what happened at the Tavistock and
everyone's realizing it's such a a
scandal and then you've got over a
thousand families suing the Tavistock I
don't even think I think you only saw
about
ten thousand people in the last five six
years aren't they and like over a
thousand families are suing it and this
is Britain it's like we're not like an
America where they just Sue anyone at
the drop of a hat you know we we're not
a litigious Society but a thousand
families suing the Tavistock very public
lost coverage you know like you know
stories of like
you know you've actually seen mainstream
newspapers like the times and Telegraph
Richie Herron a detransitioner had his
story
um out Kira Bell like these these things
so that's that's one Jenga block we've
had the the self ID gender blocks taken
away but people being like it's mental
and people normal people being
um mobilized as it were to to kind of
get together and and say actually we're
not we're not having this actually
um and yeah as I say that then you've
got the sports thing you've got the
changing rooms what I was going to say
before about Primark is that they
so many people came on Tick Tock being
like so I was just in Primark
um in Cambridge
and um
I feel really stupid
um
yeah I was trying on some clothes and it
was a unisex changing room which I'm
really full and I love that because you
know it makes everyone feel included but
twice
um two men walked opened the curtain
walked in on me
um luckily both times I had I was
wearing footy clothes but I could easily
not have been
um and I yeah it was two different
people
um clearly from the same group and there
was many like probably like 100 changing
rooms available
um so it's not like you know it was like
always someone in here or not it was you
know clearly
um and both times like I was so shocked
and I was like oh sorry like as if it
was my fault
um but yeah um I have to say that
Primark have been amazing um they were
really really good about it
um yeah they have walked me back to my
car and everything because I was scared
um apparently it's not the first time
it's happened and um security are
watching back the tapes and seeing if
they can find who it is but
yeah I just want to say to people please
be careful
um and if you go to the changing room
try not go on your own
um I will never be doing that again I
would rather take it home try it on and
then take it back and get refunded so
yeah stay safe
so many people came on Tick Tock being
like crying and saying oh someone was
filming me and the changing rooms that
they did a u-turn and they reinstated
um you know
Single Sex spaces for changing all these
things are
falling into place and I think
we are going to come out of this in
almost like a dreamlike state in a few
years being like
I can't believe that we let a very very
small minority of incredibly political
voices just yeah as you say run rampant
and we thought well you know they're
Progressive and we want to be
Progressive and good people and if they
seem to know what they're doing and
they've got degrees in like gender
Theory and queer Theory and stuff and
you know um I want to you know you know
I'm a liberal person and you know I love
gay people and you know and I don't care
if someone wants to wear a dress so you
know people think they Outsource their
thinking of this and they assume the
experts especially someone like the NHS
they assume that they will be you know
competent enough
and then you realize and like you did a
brilliant like Twitter thread in the
video about like why we've lost trust in
institutions
turns out all these institutions just
didn't have
you know the backbone or or all the
principles to stand on and this is why
why I said before well it comes back to
the other thing you said actually which
is about uh children because you talked
about how it's all about kindness but
what you didn't mention is
as part of
the demonization of men it's not
actually about men it's about what
masculinity is and part of that is
strength and Authority which we fear
more than anything in modern society and
to exercise strength and Authority is
seen as I mean quoting Jordan Peterson
here but it's seen as automatically
being conflated with tyranny right and
so to say to somebody well we understand
that you have these feelings but we are
a medical profession we don't just cut
bits off children because it's not what
we do is a sign of tyranny it's a denial
of your identity it's a denial of
medical treatment that you need out of
the kindness that we're supposed to act
with and so I think part of what you're
talking about societally where this
comes from is an unwillingness of people
to essentially be adults yes yeah yeah
um I was thinking about this yesterday
um
I think that Something's Happened in the
Millennium generation or slightly before
that maybe
where we all kind of communally took a
puberty blocker
and we literally like I think
a couple of decades we just decided I
mean like the the trans identifying
thing is a way of opting out of reality
at the end of the day it's it's your
something about yourselves that you
don't like and you're trying to
disassociate yourself from it
and I think that's what we've done I
think we've I think we saw
reality like life is difficult I have to
take responsibility
um and but we were given this kind of
opt out of adulthood and and that's
where you get a lot of adolescent
adolescentish men who are kind of your
age
um and you're not in this this camp at
all but it's like instead of like um
instead of
uh the puberty blockers we've got like
porn and just weed and gaming and just
casual sex and like all the things we
enjoy yeah indeed
so but you know I mean it's like we've
there's a way you can be that doesn't
require you to grow up and take
responsibility and one of the things
about being a man is eventually getting
to a point where you have to be the
authority and it's very uncomfortable
particularly if you haven't been
properly socialized to be in that
position yeah yeah I mean I you know the
story because I've told you but I was
dreading hiring not you specifically
although you specifically as well but
just hiring anyone because I was like
we're going to have to manage this now
you don't really know how so I know I
mean so if we're running out of time so
I before we go to locals and we'll do a
good chunk on there for people because
your your story actually raised a lot of
interest uh tell us very quickly before
we ask the last question but very
quickly about how you got peace with who
you are yeah yeah that's that's a good
point um I'm just very very grateful for
people in my life who you're welcome not
your
um
largely Christians actually who
had what I
um talked about that that balance of
Grace and Truth
um you know as a society we can go too
far towards you know Truth at the
expense of of being gracious and
um and we have done that in the past and
Christian societies have done that in
the past you know if you look at sort of
dickensian Britain and you know it's
just like you know if the poor would
rather die then they better do it and
decrease the Surplus population you know
um if anyone thinks I'm
smart for knowing Dickens that straight
from Muppets Christmas Carol but you
know I mean it's like so we have done
that and so I'm not saying Christianity
is perfect but that's why I'm saying
like if you do it right like and so
Christians are speaking to my life being
like doing what what the gender clinics
were doing back in the day which is
exploratory therapy and be like okay so
there's a reality of who you are and so
it so it really helped me to be like so
I knew with the help of other people and
with the help of the scripture as well
because I that you know it was it's
evident to me there's just no concept of
gender identity in the Bible it's like
you know you get amazing characters like
King David and he was like this amazing
King and he was also like he was a
warrior but he was also a poet and a
musician and a harp player and there's
nothing in the Bible about like well he
was being really manly when he was being
a warrior and he was but he was
exploring his feminine inside it was
just like no he's just a man and so like
you know there was that but
the kind of
holding on to
Grace and Truth really really helped me
um to
to come to peace in that because I
realized that
I was a woman with
a mind that was
disconnected from reality at times
um so a woman
and so what an ending classic Francis
but no I'm just gonna say my mind needed
to be brought into alignment with the
reality of my body
as opposed to a body that needs to be
brought into alignment of the reality of
your mind and the Bible is very
skeptical of our feelings as being the
true north so in our society we're like
your feelings and yourself sense of
identity is like the main thing whereas
the Bible always like says the exact
opposite it says that the heart is
wicked and deceitful above all things
and it can you know who can understand
it and now that is why that is why it
must be canceled now so uh it's great to
have you on the show uh please keep up
the amazing work you're doing obviously
but uh as any guest on the show you have
one final question on before we go to
locals which is of course what is the
one thing we're not talking about the
world it should be
[Music]
um
I think
the whole trans thing
is a microcosm
of
a much broader problem so you know you I
was saying about
just a failure to
bring us bring the truth and reality
into alignment with the way you want
things to be or the way you think the
things should be so the whole problem of
the
the trans identifying you know movement
is
I want my life to be like this I really
um
or it should be like this like as I say
when I was a feminist it's like it
should be like this
but
reality always bites back
um and so you're always going to be at
odds like with reality and you're never
going to find peace while you're trying
to live outside it I mean we've got a
whole world of social media telling you
you can you can you can you can well you
can't and
you know the many detransition is a
testament to that and the people who've
been betrayed by that but
I think it's a microcosm of
a broader human problem so like I think
again like what I'm saying about the US
taking puberty blockets like over the
last best part of the century
um and Peter Hitchens writes about this
brilliantly in um the rage against God
brilliant book he talks about how how
have we gone from being
this kind of country with its massive
Christian Heritage
and then suddenly like all of the
institutions and all the things of
society and that's all just Fallen away
and he sort of charts brilliantly like
certain events that happen during the
last century that really kind of uh it's
it's kind of like you you know what you
were saying in your thread about how
people lost trust in it
um in institutions the same thing
happened with Christianity over the
course of uh you know a few decades you
know with the wars and the sewers crisis
and the female Affair and all these
different things
um so the point is I think we we said
around the 60s given some of these
crises
I think the world should be like this
and I don't like the reality of the way
the world is and I'm going to live in
accordance with that and then you see
the sexual sexual Revolution obviously
which we've covered with brilliant
people like Louise Perry and Mary
Harrington just doing such a brilliant
job and Mary ever's Dad too yeah Mary
epistat yep um top level crizo
um yeah loads of people
um have been writing about this now
which is again
they tried the trans experiment it was
so extreme it's failing it's crumbling I
think what we're seeing now is what's
happening in the wake of that last best
part of a century of just let's do
things our way let's completely reject
God and the way he says that things that
life should be ordered in accordance
with thriving let's say that you know
let's throw out marriage let's throw out
um people taking responsibility for
children let's take let's throw out um
you know sex is just
you know it's just a pleasure activity
at the end of the day and we should be
able to have that and placing that as
the highest good in society the highest
value is like freedom and sexual you
know fulfillment
and then the repercussions of that you
know
Downstream are massive in terms of like
um you know people women's unhappiness
in terms of the Dayton Market trying to
have sex like like men as it were in
terms of no strings attached and and you
know trying to be this empowered sexual
being when they don't
inside a lot of them don't want that
they want to be with a man who's
committed to them and have a
relationship and have children and build
a family and build a home in a community
that's what most women want and I think
probably a lot of men want as well
um and then you've got you know the
other Downstream consequences which are
really sad like the like abortion and
just like if you if you say the highest
value in society is that I should be
able to have sex whomever I want and you
know that's the most that's the highest
priority that's the highest value
then you know the it's almost like
obligatory then that a child's life
should be sacrificed because of that
because it's like well that's that's my
right that's the most important thing
comes before responsibility and anything
else so we're seeing all these uh you
know repercussions come out of it
um and I'm sure that many people will
disagree with me and that's fine I don't
mind talking and debating with anyone
but what I'm saying is
we tried an experiment of
rejecting God I think and rejecting you
know the the true the inheritance of
Christianity that had been brought down
over hundreds of hundreds of years and I
think that's failing in many ways but
again in the same way I'm encouraged
about the the trans thing failing I
think I've seen a lot of people
interested in Christianity again and I
think that
we've seen a lot of people talking about
it more freely and moribly and I think a
lot of people
um
interested in pursuing it in a way that
they weren't before and I've seen a lot
of people
coming to Christ who have had completely
no background in it whatsoever
um and I think if you're if you'll uh
permit me to have one more minute
um the
so I talked about the trans thing as a
microcosm of like what's happened over
the last century I think that is a
microcosm of The Human Experience the
human problem which is
um you know if you if you want to look
at history if you want to look at the
Old Testament the
if you don't know what the Old Testament
is in the Bible pretty much the story of
the old the Old Testament is
um God's helps gives people like says
this is what you know this is what's
good and right and everyone's like yeah
let's do it and then after a while
they're like actually you know we're not
going to do that they start doing their
own thing
uh everything goes wrong they repent and
turn back to God and the cycle goes on
and on and on that's like the human
problem and I think that we're seeing
that come around again there you go
Sodom and gomorrah's coming but it's
going to be fine after that yeah exactly
if you give your life to Christ after
that look terrifying anyway uh Sophie
spittle thank you so much do you want
people to follow you online or yeah yeah
um just Twitter
um probably
um you need to tell them yeah Sophie
spittle uh s-p-i-t-a-l like hospital
without the ha
okay okay great uh follow us on locals
where we will continue the conversation
also I've got a sub stack in it
perfect
uh lemming Jr asks uh is there anything
which can persuade autistic people that
transitioning isn't the answer
thank you
foreign